Ein guter roter Tropfen aus dem
Holzfass kann richtig teuer werden.
Günstiger geht es mit
Holz-Chips im Stahltank.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Was für ein
intensives Aroma.
In Windeseile entsteht eine Geschmacksexplosion
aus Lakritz, Vanille und Zitrus.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Eben noch im Tetra Pak,
später in einer schicken Flasche
mit Korken und Etikett.
Können unsere Experten da noch
einen Unterschied erschmecken?
VERKOSTER 4: Er hat Gerbstoff.
Ob er im Holz ausgebaut ist,
weiß ich nicht, aber er hat Gerbstoff.
Im Auftrag der Weinkönigin hat er die
Lizenz zum Tricksen: Sebastian Lege.
Bis zu zwei Jahre liegt ein guter Rioja im
traditionellen 225-Liter-Holzfass - dem "Barrique".
Chemische Reaktionen sorgen in dieser Zeit
für die Entstehung eines komplexen Aroma-Feuerwerks .
Da Holzfässer jedoch rar und teuer sind, lagern die meisten Weine für den schnellen Verkauf
in riesigen Stahltanks
Geschmack gibt der keinen ab.
Auf das berühmte Barrique-Aroma muss man
aber keinesfalls verzichten.
Wie die Industrie setzt Sebastian dafür auf
eine scharfe Klinge und frisches Eichenholz.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Die Ausbeute.
Schöne Eichenholz Chips.
Na ja, hochwertigen Wein macht
man ja in Eichenfässern.
In Masse viel zu kostspielig.
Mit reinen Holz-Chips geben
wir uns aber nicht zufrieden.
Für ein intensiveres Aroma flambiert
Sebastian die Holz-Chips.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Was für ein intensives Aroma.
Riecht das super. Hat ein bisschen was von
Lagerfeuer, Camping Romantik. Herrlich.
Hey Sebastian - nicht abschweifen,
was passiert jetzt?
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Eine kleine Prise reicht schon,
um richtig viel Wein ein vernünftiges Holzaroma zu geben.
Tja, ich würde mal sagen,
eben noch im Tetra Pak,
später in einer schicken Flasche
mit Korken und Etikett.
Seit 2009 ist das Verfahren in der EU zugelassen.
Die Schnipsel bieten dem Wein eine
größre Angriffsfläche als das Holzfass.
Nur noch 2 Wochen muss der Trick-Wein so lagern.
ü/brigens: Winzer müssen gechipsten Wein nicht kennzeichnen.
Aber: Steht auf der Flasche "im Eichenfass gelagert"
oder "Barrique gereift"
muss dieser auch ein Fass von innen gesehen haben.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Naja, ich bin ja mal gespannt,
ob das später einer rausschmeckt,
wenn wir jetzt hier den Wein mindestens
eine Woche stehen lassen mit den Holzchips,
ob da die Leute uns auf die Schliche kommen und sagen:
"Oh, lecker! Schönes Bouquet! Im Eichenfass ausgelagert".
Nee, nee, der lagerte schön in Pappe und
wurde von uns mit Holzchips versetzt.
Ob Sebastians Trick-Wein auffliegt, wollen wir
an der Ahr in Rheinland-Pfalz herausfinden.
Die Region ist bekannt für ihre aromatischen Rotweine.
Neben Sebastians Eigenkreation für 2 Euro treten ein professioneller gechipster Australier für 5 Euro
und ein echter Barrique für 16 Euro an.
Eine Jury aus Sommeliers, Weinhändlern und Hobbywinzern stellt ihre feinen Gaumen zur Verfügung.
SEBASTIAN  LEGE: Hallo ihr Lieben.
Schön, dass ihr alle gekommen seid.
Dann haben wir ja die geballte Weinkompetenz hier
am den Tisch, und da bin ich ja mal gespannt
ob ihr das alles rausschmeckt,
was wir euch gleich kredenzen.
Fein dekantiert stehen die Weine bereit.
Wir beginnen mit dem echten Barrique-Wein.
Holzfass oder Chips?
Die Jury ist direkt auf dem richtigen Weg.
VERKOSTER 2: Ein Rotwein.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Ja, das wollte ich schon sagen,
ist schon mal richtig.
VERKOSTER 1: Also pfeffrige Note auf jeden Fall.
Würzige Note.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Würzig, pfeffrig, OK.
VERKOSTER 3: Schön.
VERKOSTER 4: Ja, ich denke, es könnte ein Fass sein,
ein Holzfass sein. Du merkst, mir gefällt der Wein.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Ja, merke ich.
Würzig, pfeffrig, im Fass gelagert -
der teure Barrique trifft auf Gegenliebe.
Ob Sebastians Billig-Version da mithalten kann?
VERKOSTER 1: Ich probiere jetzt mal, aber...
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Oh, der wurde aber schnell ausgespuckt.
VERKOSTER 4: Kann sein, dass er Kork hat? Ein Wein-Fehler?
VERKOSTER 5: Der riecht wie...
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Der riecht wie?
VERKOSTER 5: Naturtrüber Apfelsaft.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Naturtrüber Apfelsaft?!
VERKOSTER 4: Der riecht nicht nach Wein,
der riecht so ein bisschen mehr nach Muffton.
Mufton? Ich dachte der riecht nach ...
VERKOSTER 3: Spanien. Meine ich.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Extrem guter Tropfen.
VERKOSTER 1: Nein.
VERKOSTER 2: Also, so was habe ich noch nie getrunken.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Nein?
VERKOSTER 2: Nein.
VERKOSTER 4: Der kann niemals im Holzfass gewesen sein,  da leg ich meine Hand für ins Feuer.
Das ist ein Stahltankwein.
Die Kenner sind Sebastians Weintrick auf die Schliche gekommen. Aber fällt damit auch die Chipsmethode durch?
Wir schicken den australischen Wein
aus dem Supermarkt ins Rennen.
Auch der wurde mit Eichenspänen versetzt.
VERKOSTER 1: Schöne Nase, auf jeden Fall,
kann ich gleich sagen.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Das ist ja schon mal schön.
VERKOSTER 2: Also dieser Wein hat
tatsächlich als erster, den Tannin-,
also die Gerbstoffe merkt man auf der Zunge auch.
Der könnte auch im Fachhandel stehen.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: OK.
VERKOSTER 2: Könnte er.
VERKOSTER 1: Der ist gut.
SEBASTIAN LEGE: Was meinst du bei dem -
im Holz ausgebaut?
VERKOSTER 4: Er hat Gerbstoff.
Ob er im Holz ausgebaut ist, weiß ich nicht,
aber er hat Gerbstoff.
Der Chips-Wein aus dem Supermarkt kommt überraschend gut an.
Während der Lagerung sind offenbar genügend
Gerbstoffe vom Holz in den Wein übergegangen.
Gechipst bedeutet also nicht gleich schlecht.
Im Gegensatz zu Sebastian setzt die Industrie
aber auf ein deutlich komplizierteres Verfahren.
Für jede Weinsorte unterscheidet sich die
ideale Größe und Rüstung der Holzchips.
Zur Erinnerung: Ob der Wein gechipst wurde oder nicht,
sehen wir auf der Flasche nicht.
Und auch die Aufschrift "Barrique" oder "im Eichenfass" gelagert verspricht nicht immer Top-Qualität.
Bei Weinen unter zehn Euro werden nicht selten alte Fässer verwendet, die kaum noch Geschmack abgeben.
Ein günstiger "gechipster" Wein kann da
durchaus vollmundiger sein.
Nicht in Fässern gereift, aber dafür genauso
lecker, lagern auf unserem Kanal
Tricks, Checks und Duelle aus der Welt der Lebensmittel.